pour la rentrée donc des pmp de retour
bien entendu à la rentrée forcément
sachez que tpm paix va encore repartir
pour je vous le dis au moins deux à
trois saisons
voilà non je ne vois là avec moi
j'espère si vous voulez toujours de moi
les chroniqueurs bien entendu voilà donc
on va repartir pour deux à trois saisons
de tp ce qui veut dire qu'on arriverait
souhaitant 13e saison qui serait une
grosse voilà on espère maintenant ce
qu'on veut c'est juste vous accompagner
tous les soirs on espère que tout ça va
s'arranger on espère qu'on va pouvoir
vous divertir et sachez qu'à la rentrée
il y aura énormément de nouveautés aussi
dans touche pas à mon poste
on va garder l'équipe telle qu'elle est
il y aura également des petits nouveaux
dont un très beau gosse voilà alors de
jean pascal
tout ce que je peux vous dire voilà
c'est tout ce que je peux vous dire
voilà l'égérie je vous en dirai un petit
peu plus tous les jours voilà
mais merci non j'ai dit un très beau
gosse jean-michel merci oui jean louis
destans si je vous ai dit pas mal de
souffrances eux ceux qui pensaient que
voie lactée pmp c'était aller à les
reprendre là on va par contre cette
saison mais on va reprendre
voilà en tout cas un truc avec les
chroniqueurs tout ça qui va normalement
vous plaire avec des conneries comme
vous aimez moi je vous dis et puis 71
pmp stp mp je vous dis pour au moins
deux voire trois saisons encore voilà
derrière donc voilà je vous dit tout et
je vous dirai toujours tous les chéris